I'm dr. roshni rod I'm an internist and
gastroenterologist and an associate
professor of Medicine I'm dr. Gail Saltz
I am clinical associate professor of
psychiatry I am a family medicine
practitioner and I'm here today to talk
to you about why we should not be
putting laundry detergent pods in your
mouth I can't believe I have to say that
one twenty eighteen already there's been
39 cases in the last two weeks which is
enormous in comparison to previous years
and it's in response to a prank or a
meme teenagers or even adults have taken
this challenge where they are swallowing
detergent pods this is a horrible idea
it can be very damaging not only to your
mouth but to your esophagus and your
stomach your lungs potentially and in
some cases it can even be fatal
long before this challenge was an issue
very young children who came upon a pod
were at risk for eating it or swallowing
it because they mistook it for a candy
pretty small and so like bite sized and
so I think the idea is like well if it's
bite size then it can't be that harmful
it's brightly colored it's multicolored
it's squishy has a smooth coating that
can be manipulated people often want to
hold it manipulate it or unfortunately
put it in their mouth the detergent pods
contain in many cases either bleach like
detergents or other what we call
surfactants which are very damaging
chemicals when your body is exposed to
them we have a very delicate lining of
our esophagus in our stomach and even
our mouth and this can be easily burned
by these types of chemicals when you
first put one of these pods in your
mouth it's very likely to explode
because it's just kind of contained in a
plastic coating it can dissolve with a
quick bite and it also can dissolve was
just like mouth moisture so it doesn't
necessarily have to be you chomping down
on it and this explosion in your mouth
can cause severe burning of the
membranes that are lining your mouth and
your throat if you then swallow the pot
it can go on to cause severe burning of
your esophagus this kind of damage could
even cause a tear in your esophagus or
an actual hole and long term could lead
to narrowing or stricture of the
esophagus it can really irritate or burn
the lining of your stomach and
take your intestines as well when you're
taking a bite of it if you actually end
up inhaling it then you can get some of
the laundry detergent into your lungs
and at that point it can irritate sort
of the lung lining causing you to cough
wheeze have shortness of breath and in
some really serious incidents this can
cause sort of inflammation in the lungs
leading to pulmonary edema which is
water in the lungs and acute respiratory
distress syndrome where there's too much
inflammation for you to be able to
breathe taking a high risk prank to the
nth degree is not new and young adults
are very drawn to high risk behaviors
for biological reasons the amygdala sort
of says to the rest of the brain hey
that felt good let's do it again which
is why this age group as a particular
risk for doing things that otherwise
they might deem a poor idea this is such
a disturbing trend on many levels I
think because of social media teenagers
are doing a lot of things that maybe
they wouldn't have done twenty years ago
just because they don't have an audience
for it so the same dynamic can be a play
for example with something like the ALS
bucket challenge where you know we're
like wildfire it took on it's simply the
phenomenon that large groups can see an
activity and can get feedback for that
activity but much more quickly because
of social media you absolutely can die
from ingesting laundry detergent pods
for adults it's not necessarily gonna be
the pods themselves that lead to their
risk of death meaning you can get
seizures you can get pulmonary edema or
you can just have a significant
infection that can develop as well if
you're worried about someone you know
potentially swallowing a pod certain
symptoms to look out for abdominal pain
vomiting nausea fever right away you
want to drink a glass of water you want
to drink some milk to dilute the
detergent you want to help poison
control right away make sure to have
details what was actually ingested the
concentration the ingredients you really
don't want to make them vomit that can
actually lead to aspiration of the own
vomit or choking on your own vomit but
if any of the symptoms ever get really
serious you have to call 911 and get to
the closest emergency room if you make
something taboo that's simply going to
Stoke them an adolescent and young adult
this desire to
take risk this desire to the
anti-authoritarian may promote the
desire to do just that
when these kinds of trends come up
watching media you would have the
feeling that everybody is doing
something hey everybody's doing it it
must be okay really look at the numbers
which do remain very small therefore
keep that in mind please do not put
laundry detergent pods in your mouth
even if you think it's funny if someone
dares you whatever it may be if it
reminds you of candy just don't do it
[Music]